what up guys uh the other day I've
spoken a really interesting food and
agricultural keynote this is an
incredible keynote for a lot of people
in the b2b sector or the traditional you
know 100 million dollar-plus business
sectors there's an email key note that
you should forward to a bunch of your
dad's and grandpas and grandmas and
grandpas and just like very interesting
talk I felt I mean this was I was
brilliant his own I hope you agree
[Music]
morning very very happy to be here
really enjoyed the opening monologue in
in the context of today's morning I
tweeted just now it's been interesting
over the last 72 hours whether in a Wall
Street Journal interview or a business
meeting now a conference and a lot of
one-on-one meetings I've heard the same
thing about 11 or 12 times and it struck
me finally this last time on stage which
is how many people keep saying the word
or the sentence it's changing its
changing I think anybody here this
morning that hasn't fully quantified how
much has actually changed this has
changed I think there is an unbelievable
disconnect between the framework and
strategy of how we are running our
businesses whether it be to B or B to C
environment on us calibrating is it
changing or has it changed and more
importantly the practicality of the
timing I spend very little time on the
impact of self-driving cars in a micro
in a 24 or 36 month window but I try to
under understand and quantify them in a
macro and I think the thing that I've
spent and I'm a and I'm a real hardcore
purebred entrepreneur just to give you
guys context on the cross lines here I
was born in the Soviet Union came to the
US lived in a studio apartment half the
size of this stage with eight family
members very old school merchant
upbringing my dad got a job as a stock
boy in a liquor store and we saved all
our dollars I'm super an enigma all the
Russian Jews that emigrated were
straight-a students I was a straight DNF
student
you know and it's really interesting I'm
extremely bitter now because I was
making three to four thousand dollars a
weekend when I was twelve
selling baseball cards because that was
the cultural phenomenon but I was a
loser because I was getting D's and F's
because it was the late 80s early 90s
and the only ROI was the college you
were going to if I was making $4,000 a
weekend selling baseball cards today I
would be the next Mark Zuckerberg and on
covers of magazines and so you know I'm
very fascinated by friends by things
that happen but I think the thing that
has really worked for me is I didn't
realize probably into the last decade
you know I take a lot of pride when I
was an early investor long two three
four years pre IPO or acquisition on
things like Twitter and Facebook and
venmo and uber I'm not in the luck
business I'm in the marathon running
business and more importantly I'm in the
timing business I'm so deeply actually
consumer centric that I don't have any
other gear the only thing I ever do is
try to reverse-engineer the attention of
my end consumer whether in a b2c or b2b
environment and I try to understand
things like it blows my mind how many
people here feel comfortable because
they have long-term contracts and
relationships with some of the biggest
companies in the world without realizing
that those companies themselves are so
disproportionately vulnerable and and I
just you know I play with this right I
play with the fact that 80 billion
dollars is spent on television
commercials on the fortune 500 CPG brand
side yet 94% of them lost market share
because not a human being on earth
watches a television commercial none and
by the way can we all agree this is not
a fourteen-year-old girl crowd right we
are a little bit older here but not old
everybody here has got plenty of time
how many people actually you know what
let me frame up my entire talk here
before I go any further how many people
in this room are retiring within the
next ten years
not because you're gonna crush it and
cash out but because you're actually
just old just raise your hands okay all
right so for the 13 of you I think
a level of grain of a salt we can take
going forward but for the rest of you I
want to tell you something that I really
want to get across as a framework to the
strategy of why this conversation is
disproportionally important and how you
know and I work with companies like I
say P and GE and and a bunch of food
service companies so I have a real sense
of context in this room I want to leave
you with this proportion of practicality
of why I think you need to look at your
marketing spend or more importantly why
you need to start debating a marketing
spend because you are a sales driven
organization and a b2b environment you
are disproportionally vulnerable so we
need to talk about that but before we
get into that here's why I asked that
ten-year question literally nothing we
talked about or way more importantly
literally nothing that controls the
attention of our end consumer existed 13
years ago we need to take a big step
back in this room and understand what we
are talking about is not social media or
snapchat what we are talking about is
the maturity of the Internet itself what
that means to the human race and
everybody in this room including me is
so disproportionally misunderstanding
how substantial this shift is and what
happens over the course of the next
decade the Internet is the middleman
period and it's maybe just not your turn
it was the bookstore's turn first it was
some guy or gal that owned 13 medallions
in taxis in this city second or third it
is the hotel rooms and the supply and
demand of that world's turn today it is
the media companies across the board
stern right now and it may be your
business next Walmart's not going to
give you the contract Walmart's gonna
have to do it itself they're gonna be
they're gonna buy dairy farms they're
gonna grow the grain everything gets
shrunk and so we have to take a real
step back and understand that there is
only one thing one there's one thing
that will keep you from being a
commodity your brand the only thing that
will keep you away from being completely
commoditized is your brand can you
create an environment where somebody
actually makes an emotional decision
or a subconscious decision not a
practical one because if you're in the
middle and people are gonna make
practical decisions there's an enormous
amount of vulnerability in the system we
are completely and utterly controlled by
this device whether you like it or not
please my friends do not make business
decisions because of your personal
romantic point of view of Technology the
amount of people here that will dictate
their businesses to failure because of
their points of view of when they go out
they find it sad that people look at
their phones instead of talk to each
other is staggering to me and so look
this is real disruption this isn't haha
this is over the course of the next
decade 90 80 70 percent of the biggest
companies in multiple sectors will not
only decline but completely diminish and
completely vanish you know I look at the
fashion industry it's just so
fascinating literally they're all out of
business the math is just not going to
work every day there are brands that go
from 0 to 15 million dollars in sales on
the back of influencers on Instagram
with no overhead or infrastructure at
scale and the cut of those thousand cuts
is staggering and this all is on top of
you can talk like this we can talk about
food trends and the behavior of the end
of the consumer
that's absolutely right that's fine that
is minor leagues compared to the
fundamental human shifts were going
through did anybody see the robot that
went viral on the internet the other day
there's like robot that was doing like
twists and turns how many people just
raise your hands I'm curious did you see
what Elon Musk said about it which was
so there's this robe you have the finest
I don't have a lot of data on there so
you know in the feed you know in the
headline reading society I don't like to
talk about things I don't know here's
what I know a robot that scared the crap
out of me
was in my feet right just doing stuff
that makes LeBron look like me right
Elon Musk decides to take that somebody
more educated in robotics than I am and
said something very clever and I know
enough about how he communicates where
he's like you think this is cute
in 2436 model member of the time
very shortly you won't even be able to
see this robot without technology that
it would be so fast that the human eye
can't even see it now why do I bring
that up I bring that up because it's a
proxy it's a proxy to the following
everybody in this room needs to realize
that we are about to run an incredibly
fascinating business marathon and most
of you aren't even on the treadmill yet
and let me explain the treadmill to me
is how you spend your money on marketing
and sales the one place that you could
leave here today walk out the door fly
home and do something about what I'm
talking about is how you spend money to
get revenue in I am fascinated by people
in the b2b space to think it's ROI
positive to buy booths and full-page ads
and b2b magazines
in 2018 and not understand how Facebook
advertising works to become a top of the
funnel conversion sales funnel for their
business
I'm fascinated I am fascinated that a
room like this with as many successful
people as sit in these chairs have
unbelievable opinions of Facebook
advertising without ever running a
Facebook ad in their lives you have a
whole lot of opinions based on stock
prices or a headline you read or what
the Wall Street Journal wrote on the
issue nine months ago yet you lack
practitioner ship to understand exactly
what's happening here and we are living
through the great divide right now my
friends of the headline readers and the
practitioners when it comes to running
businesses and by the way that last line
society all these confusions of how
things are changing is the deep either
lack of interest to look at it because
it's so heady that it's so scary to
understand how big of a ship this is or
the naivete or Wolf's worst of all the
audacity every business that is CFO
driven short term 90 day driven
financial arbitrage machines are on-call
because they haven't quantified that the
ground that they're standing on has
changed and that's been a stable ground
in consumer behavior look consumer
behaviors super
for the last 70 years what we don't
quantify is that for the last 70 years
the propaganda that made you make
business decisions stayed the same
it was print television radio Direct
Mail it was basic the Internet is such a
harder place to navigate and what's
interesting and let me take a step back
to frame up what my passion is my
opening rants that's on I only have one
move how many people here by show of
hands are familiar with Mariano Rivera
the New York Yankees pitcher that
pitched for 20 years I'm just curious
because I want to use the analogy ok
good enough I'll use it 20 years
closer for the Yankees goes down as one
of the great all-time players of all
time the guy had one pitch we had others
for the baseball nerds in here but the
fact the matter is he had one pitch and
nobody could hit it Edgar Martinez from
the Mariners could hit it nobody could
hit it for 20 years that's what I have
I suck at most things but I will buy the
New York hits and win seven Super Bowls
which will cost me billions of dollars
because I have one pitch and is what I'm
trying to shove down the throat of this
room which is I day trade attention and
you better start understanding what I
mean by that
i day trade attention no matter what you
do in this room for the people
presenting to the most senior executive
here whether you have a side business
when you go home that your passion
amount which is selling jelly
direct-to-consumer on Amazon I don't
know you and I don't know what you're up
to but let me promise you the one thing
that I can talk about that connects
everybody here and will bring value to
everybody is before you tell me how good
your thing is you need my attention
many rely on historic nature's of the
business the sales funnel the b2b nature
the contracts the way it's been others
25% of this room probably spend their
time thinking about the consumer how
many people here actually are in b2c
businesses raise your hands just curious
just higher if you don't mind because I
want to navigate my talk thank you b2b
rest okay I'm fascinated let me let me
go very tactical on you because I really
want to go to Q&A
so I want to set up as much framework
but I'm gonna go a little tactical maybe
I'll spur a question
I'm watching SAS companies that have a
million dollars in funding you know
create disproportionate wealth by
running Facebook ads against the
employees of segmentation I believe that
a lot of people in this room don't
understand that their company can run
ads against the employees of an
organization that are trying to do
business with that ad may say does your
head buyer know does your CIO know does
your CFO know the fact that I can run
ads that cost me $4 CPMs that are
actually being consumed and that the
creative of the video or the
presentation or the white paper or the
paragraph or the image with words on it
starts with copy in the post that says
does your blank within your organization
know which then leads to between 1.3
percent and 4 percent of people
forwarding it to that person whether
janitor or c-suite co-worker to then
convert in top of funnel is something
I've never seen in b2b in the 20 years
of being a practitioner in marketing
both traditional and Direct Mail and
radio and television and outdoor and
digital my passion sits here today
because I know that Facebook is the
disproportionate arbitrage for this room
and I also am empathetic to know why
nobody would believe that in a b2b
environment in this room but it doesn't
make it any less true and because
building my dad's business from a 3 to a
60 million dollar business which was a
liquor store in New Jersey over a five
year window with no dollars at all no
cash infusion no VC was very difficult
but the only reason I pulled it off is
because I day traded attention in 1996 I
started an email newsletter when nobody
was doing that and I had 91% open rates
for the first four years of my career
which is unheard of and then Google came
out and I bought wine terms on Google
for five cents a click from the word
wine to the word Silver Oak and when I
hear and it wasn't in the bio here but a
lot of times they're like and he took
his business from 3 to 60 million I
cringed in the corner before I come on
because I say to myself it should have
been 250 and the reason it should have
been 250 was because I was one of the
first advertisers on
AdWords because I was on there the day
it came out it was so grossly
underpriced attention but I was too
young to understand that it was so big
that it was a once-in-a-lifetime a twice
in a lifetime maybe a three times in a
lifetime in my 60-year career arbitrage
to build wealth on such underpriced
attention I stand here with this energy
because I have a chip on my shoulder
because I'm mad that I didn't understand
it and that I spent money on direct mail
and print and radio and sales and many
other things how many people here play
poker
raise your hands thank you when you have
the best hand you go all-in I had it and
I didn't the best hand as I stand here
today and I could care less if it's not
tomorrow cuz I day trade is Facebook and
you have to at a bare minimum understand
how to start spending money in that
world not because it's gonna be so
disproportionately ROI positive for your
business though I think any dollar spent
there if you actually know how to do it
will be better than what you spend
anywhere else it's because you need to
start at the top
creating a cadence to understand how to
market and sell in the new environment
that we live in there is no way that you
will be an organization that has success
and machine learning and AI and any
other things that are gonna happen from
2020 to 2030 if you don't understand how
to communicate in the mobile first
environment that is today you will not
have the taste or understanding and to
be very frank some won't even get there
and so it's a very fascinating time and
the stakes are extremely high
you know when I look at the the
businesses in this room from afar when I
look at the current marketplace I get
enormous passion because it's so
avoidable but the problem is even the
three people in this room that are
inspired and are actually going to do
something about this will outsource it
and not become the practitioners
themselves which will then create the
vulnerability because 95% of the
execution of the thesis that I just
talked about right here is garbage and
is being done in the best interest of
the partner not necessarily your
organization we live in a very tricky
world in my thesis of day trading
attention the Superbowl is the number
one under priced asset here I am talking
about digital and crap like machine
learning and even for b2b companies I
think the best thing you could spend
money on is the Super Bowl in North
America because you know every single
American will know what you have to say
if you actually execute that 30-second
spot properly it's a hundred percent
penetration it's under priced at seven
million dollars a pop meanwhile a lot of
you spend money on digital may spend
money on digital most likely not because
I was digging a lot of sales driven
we'll get into that in a minute and I
believe that programmatic digital buying
is the most garbage overpriced marketing
in the marketplace that nobody in this
room just like they don't consume a
commercial ever goes to a website and
carefully consumes a banner ad below the
fold and then clicks that banner and
gets into the funnel yet billions of
dollars being poured into that
environment and so what's tricky about
it is in a keynote environment like this
I can only go top-line in reality
there's so much depth underneath this
thesis in the practitioner ship but what
is most important is understanding what
happens with the next chapter of
companies that own the attention Amazon
and Google and Facebook and Apple are
not kidding around
they're building a layer on top of the
Internet itself the Internet is where we
live our lives this is now secondary
whether you like it or not by the
allocation of attention time it just is
this is secondary and it's gonna get
extreme in a vr world and for a lot of
us we will never see it but you think
this is intense you think it's bad kids
are on iPads during dinner kids are
gonna live in pods in San Diego and be
in the Internet 20 hours a day we will
see that 20 30 40 years once VR VR is
the only potential technology at this
point that can arbitrage the internet
out itself the majority of this room
and I'm looking at the faces and the
ages will wear contact lenses that mix
them between real-life a r-right like
Santa Claus is giving me the keynote
with me right now
or VR you're just literally in a
different place right now and so this
phone that seems so intense and like you
can't live without it this is a pager
remember those pagers this Cruden
remembers the pager so in fact you know
there are people in this room who said
they would never get a mobile device
because their pager was good enough and
if they needed to get a hold of you I'll
get back to you and I can get back to
you so another thing I want to talk
about because I think it might I'm gonna
go very high level but I do think for
this kind of room some people will
understand this this is what I'm
spending all my time on this is why I
believe that the Alexa and the Google
home and the apple pod are the next
arbitrage and I think a lot of you
should think about this and this is
where sales people can become
disproportionately trained or arbitrage
doubt that completely let's talk about
it at the top of the framework the
reason I invested in uber years ago was
not because I thought they sold
transportation it was because they sold
you back time every person here besides
health wealth and religion and their
family put time in the pedestal of the
things that matter to them the most you
do it every day you give up privacy you
spend tons of money to arbitrage time
uber doesn't sell transportation uber
sells the perception of time the thing
that will sell the most time back to us
over the next decade will be Voice
devices that are smart I buy toothpaste
now in my bathroom in one second through
Alexa I don't make a note I don't grab
my phone and buy it on Amazon I say
Alexa order me toothpaste she says sure
I say buy this and the transaction is
done how many of you have an Amazon echo
or dot or a Google home device in your
homes raise your hands
great most people are using it for music
which is nice but where this device is
going is staggering and the potential is
enormous
I saw startup the other day for example
that I'm probably gonna invest in that
you say Alexa I'm reading the book you
tell them the book you know Jack and
Jill you start reading the book to your
child and as you're
the Alexa is doing a surround sound
narrative along with you in unison you
say and then it started raining and the
whole room sounds like it's raining
there will be not a child on earth in
seven years that will accept a book read
to them without 360 supported sound more
importantly the things that you will do
in your car when you travel when you
think of it to use a voice device to get
it done reorder your product thus
mortification when an IOT device when
technology is in our food and it's
reordering itself for you every person
here is going to have a smart
refrigerator in a decade that reorders
the products in your refrigerator for
you Amazon's vulnerability is no
retailer that has physical locations I
don't care what M&A activity walmart has
Amazon's vulnerability is the smart home
that reorders products for you without
you doing it for them Toll Brothers is a
bigger competitor Amazon if when you buy
a new home it is stocked with products
that just keep reordering themselves for
you when you go into that kitchen cabin
for the first time and the toothpaste in
deodorant is picked for you because it's
free and it just three orders itself
when it's being used up when your Crest
toothpaste understands you've got one
goddamn squeeze left and it reorders
itself for you and it comes just as
you're squeezing it out you'll start
understanding what I mean and every
person in this room will see it my
friends please do me one favor and this
is the advantage you have over the 25
year old that gets it you underestimated
the Internet 13 years ago please take
your mental place back to where it was
remind yourself of the embarrassment
statements that you made like the
Internet itself is a fad 15 years ago
Facebook was a fad and you would never
be on it that you would never send an
emoji please please understand that I
only have one pitch and here it is I
know what you're gonna do before you do
because we like to say no before we say
yes but we have no choice
now you live your life how you want you
know how to parent and grandparent you
do with your money what you want blah
blah blah blah blah but do not bring
that to the business environment your
responsibility as an executive is to be
a hundred percent unemotional on these
issues when it comes to the business
environment that's what we do
and so please leave your opinions at
home on what's happening to the human
race let me remind you that Elvis
shaking his hips was once considered a
devil move understand this is all
evolution the robots will kill us in the
end hopefully not for us to see but
realize that the upside of this next
decade all this conversation I just had
I'm curious how this is going through
your head because for me everything out
of my mouth for the last 20 minutes sets
up offense the problem is so many people
are successful have scale and they see
defense and what comes out of my mouth
you have leverage in the distribution or
the business architecture you've created
so this disruption of that is not
interesting because your leverage sits
in distribution the problem is all
distribution of all kinds is now
commoditized and so what you need to do
is what I try to do every day of my life
I will go into my office today and I
will try to put myself out of business I
will go into my office today and try to
put myself out of business I will look
at what we do and I will try to
understand who can come along and kill
us if I don't make the long-term
investment to make short-term P&L
decisions for your own bonuses the stock
price the board or what have you in
today's environment is business suicide
because every company has to make
long-term investments because the see
changes are so extraordinary I run an
agency we're gonna do a 114 million in
revenue this year from zero six years
ago we're gonna make 1.4 million dollars
a profit triple-checked yesterday
right we made 1.4 million in profit the
third year when we did six million why
because I'm losing millions of dollars
building capabilities around voice and
machine learning nai and messenger and
everything else that I know in 36 months
the Pepsi's and Coca Cola's and
Budweiser's and Nikes of the world are
gonna need to have a chance to succeed
it's not fun for my the saddest human on
earth is my CFO
he literally hates his life
I feel so man afraid because I want to
give him autonomy and I respect his
position and I let him do his thing and
then you know he gets to the goal line
and I sent him all the way back because
it's the only framework that has success
in today's environment the lack of risk
and chances people are taking in here
even though they know they are right
because of playing for the short-term
oftentimes for your own human selfish
reasons because of the timing of how
long you will be in that position is the
fascinating thing to me in the business
environment today short-term stuff works
in the past
Wall Street dynamics work bonus
structures worth it worked it will not
and that is why the long term players
will continue to eat up attention and
deploy anything they want Amazon and
Google and Apple Facebook are not gonna
stop at the things I mean I was I was I
was so stunned and disappointed by the
collective surprise of Amazon buying
Whole Foods I was stunned I'm just
shocked that so many smart people were
like whoa whoa what how do you think
this plays out you don't chase banks
biggest competitor is Amazon like what
what do you think is happening here this
is the biggest cultural shift to the
human race since the printing press and
it magnifies by 10x do you understand
the ramifications of the blockchain you
can talk about Bitcoin
being 10,000 all day you long that is
the pager to what the blockchain is
blockchain decentralizes the human race
blockchain not Bitcoin not aetherium
blockchain is something that Russia
America and China agree on and will stop
because it's their biggest vulnerability
everything in the middle is vulnerable
all of you are in the middle and so now
what I think what happens is the
following I'm gonna throw you for a real
loop here I'm gonna close with this
because I really want to go into Q&A and
let me set up the Q&A the reason I
really want to do Q&A is I've made my
statement you're gonna have other talks
I kind of was listening to the agenda
I'm desperate for people to ask very
basic 101 questions because my intent
when I speak is to get one or two people
to do something I have no ambition to
get five ten twenty thirty percent of
this room to act on this thesis it's
just not practical in their short-term
financial interest but if I get one two
or three so for those people that are
curious please get ready simple
questions how does a b2b food service
provider or use Facebook to get an extra
account I don't care where ever you want
to go but before we go there you know I
really want to talk about the fact that
the the historical legacy stakes are
very high of what I'm talking about the
compounded nature of the marketplace is
very high of what I'm talking about
here's what I mean by that the scale
that we now live in is so extreme the
ability to go from zero to a million to
a hundred million is so quick because of
how much attention is in these phones
you have to look at it most practical
this gem I hear what the nice yellow tie
is working while this is happening this
is just which I'm cool with do your
thing
but I but but a bit but it's fun for me
right because you have to understand how
incredible that is that is not something
we could all do 15 years ago like
there's just I'm trying to really push
through here like please like stop under
estimating stop under estimating you
have sales staff how many people here to
have sales staff raise your hands
great let me talk to you what I think
you should do you should start an
internal podcast that you program every
week that is made for your sales team
because the toolkits and the PDFs and
the emails and the off sites and
awarding one guy the good thing he did
that we all want you to do a year award
at the end is not doing what you need
but they are on the move they are
consuming content that's scale in their
car they can listen to your podcast
which is internal and all 1,600 of them
can listen and you can push propaganda
down their throat 24/7 if you understand
how to give them value in 60 percent of
the content entertainment escapism
something that benefits them so that you
can subtly bring in yours in I believe
that the businesses in this room have to
take a page out of something that has
been done historically by companies like
the Michelin tire company and Guinness
beers come Peniel Eve the people in this
room that understand that they are now a
media company first comma and then
whatever comes out of your mouth or is
on your business card that you will have
the framework of success for the next
decade let me explain I believe that if
you understand why the michelin tire
company a hundred years ago decided to
start reviewing villas and hotels and
restaurants throughout Europe because
they wanted people to start driving and
using up their cars and stopping at
their stations and getting gas and more
importantly changing tires they started
pumping propaganda a guide in the cities
of London and Paris which remarkably and
coincidentally scored all the best foie
gras and champagne lists 40 miles
outside the city and forced people to go
and see what this three-star Chateau was
and they used a media property to create
the business behavior that they wanted
that the Guinness Book came out because
Guinness was losing market share in pubs
but knew that people talked about trivia
and fun facts in the pubs through their
market research and created the Guinness
Book of World Records because they would
hope that you would talk about a 17-foot
man and then the Guinness brand would be
reinforced and it would come out of your
mouth at the pub these are two
historically unbelievably successful
media executions my belief is that if
you actually understood in the same way
that it is impossible for you to not
have a CFO or a controller it is
impossible for you not to have a head of
sales I believe for most of your
organisation's in the next five to ten
years it will be impossible for you not
to have an editor-in-chief of your
business you are not at the mercy of the
in-between media companies you can go
direct you can start the most meaningful
podcast you can start the most
meaningful podcast tomorrow for all the
franchisee owners of every q sr company
in america by giving them information
that makes them run their business
better and then use all of that
attention to deploy what you want to
accomplish in your business you can it's
super far-fetched it doesn't feel
comfortable but it didn't feel
comfortable for the executives that the
nintendo company to switch from being a
playing card company to a board game
company to a video game company the
evolution that is needed in the
strategies in this room when it comes to
marketing and sales are extraordinary
they're extraordinary and please do not
rely on what got you here it's exactly
what is not going to allow you to get to
the next stage so that's where I'm at
that's what I'm thinking about I want to
I want to put a couple more points on
and where are the runners for the QA
just got a couple okay go awesome
just raise your hands in a second just
looking at the timing I'll leave with
this and then we'll do some Q&A we'll
take it from there
and please think about your question
much bigger better companies than yours
went out of business
it's history and what is happening now
to the infrastructure of our society is
something we're gonna have to navigate
so please check your audacity at the
door nobody cares about your contracts
or your history
it's your vulnerability thank you
[Applause]
you sort of find our our question who's
got a question do we have anybody me oh
we've got lots of hands yeah all right
we'll start out over there it's the
greatest keynote ever give me anyway
hey hurry interesting thank you what's
your name Oh Roy Oscar right I'm curious
with your mindset right now we're to
take your marketing spin yes how do you
see that potentially shifting with
repeal of net neutrality that's a super
great question to write one thing you
can you can see I can peacock with the
best of them I hate to answer stuff that
I haven't fully quantified I'm spending
a ton of time of trying to play not only
the short look guys like me and gals
like me there's a lot to be said like
screw you the Tollbooth this is terrible
I'm a funny you know it's so funny maybe
I'm an intense capitalism because I was
born in communism and right I'm so
fascinated by the countermove let's say
the place through what next cool so the
ISPs are this but why can't Facebook and
Google and Apple arbitrage that out by
deploying all you know great everything
gets overcharged great you have Verizon
and they give you Yahoo blistering fast
for free but Google costs $50 a month
something a lot of people here I've not
quantified their head around that is a
very real statement and I mean like this
right everybody's like you know with no
headline readings at math hour this and
this like everybody's paying attention
to so many things you wake up and in 18
months you're paying $50 a month for the
right to use Google that's like what the
hell just happened right but here's
what's funny about the game what happens
next is more interesting right as they
start getting fat the people that are
getting commoditized by them and hurt
have the ability to arbitrage them out
I'm suddenly it's so pump I'm so
thrilled you brought up that question
that's my biggest fear here there's a
lot of people here who play in a isp net
neutrality environment in their business
they think they've got it locked up
until their customers out of business
until their customers being squeezed so
much by the innovators of Tesla or
Facebook or Amazon that they have to
start changing their business model and
they don't want you to make profit
anymore
it's not about is Walmart or McDonald's
go out of business is it that they were
losing enough biz
this that they don't want you to make a
penny ever again so what do I think I
think it I think day trading attention
is something I'd become committed to
which is I think about it when it
becomes the reality and I just do it
immediately I spend time trying to be
thoughtful about these things you can't
predict a lot of things I made a video
nine months ago that said Instagram was
in trouble because snapchat was
exploding Facebook's much younger than
people think a week later and they
copied everything of snapchat and their
disproportionate most important platform
to market if you care about consumers
twenty-five to forty in North America so
I think it's potentially annoying
potentially dangerous feels really not
fun but there's places that have it you
can look at what porch of those market
looks like but I don't think they're
ready to pay eleven bucks a month for
Facebook being the speed it is now
versus it being free but taking an hour
do you know Matt everybody gets here
when their internet is a hundredth of a
second slower than what they're
accustomed to right I mean so I think
it's a very interesting toll booth and
I'm excited to watch it play out but but
I don't get crippled on what if I'm more
worried than everybody here's wasting
money right now tomorrow and that's why
when people talk about VR and AR or it's
changing or it's coming I'm like no no
no what are you doing today
where was your money like do you know
you know what's fun is not being at the
mercy of sales people and their
commissions and structures and bonuses
brand have the leverage brand is the
only leverage we have questions
gentlemen here yeah ok sing table how
are you good thank you
what's your name I'm Annie Annie I have
a question how do you transfer can you
hear me yes I have how do you translate
taste which is key to what we do food
and AG how do you translate that on the
internet or through virtual reality or
whatever the the format is the historic
translator of taste that over indexes is
called video a human being articulates
through a visual and words
what they are experiencing and we
consume it right like none of this stuff
is any different than anything happens
the same thing that Julia Child's did
that Emeril did that many other things
have been done is being done now by
somebody on Instagram in a one-minute
video I think everything is translated
through three core things audio video
and the written word the end how
everybody consumes information here is
different the historical upside is in
video
it's the biggest penetrator of our
psyche I would say video but where and
how much you can make an $800,000 video
that is a commercial and television on
the Food Network that not a soul will
watch in my opinion you can make a
youtube video in 2006 when nobody else
was doing it and get a tremendous land
grab I think about a pension like real
estate I want you to buy beachfront
property in Malibu 63 years ago right
not overpriced you know real estate on
the you know Meatpacking District in
Manhattan and I think that's what the
majority of people do because it's tried
and true without understanding how
overpriced it is who's got it let's go
down the center there okay how are you
very well that was a quite frightening
thank you Nick
from Rabobank about two things one why
Facebook why not Instagram - whatever in
Twitter and also you talked a lot about
attention and we keep hearing that the
attention span was of people is getting
shorter and shorter so help you maintain
so when I talk about Facebook you can
hold the mic for a second this might be
a follow up um Facebook and Instagram
owned by the same company I when I talk
it's a nuance of the business talk I do
want to talk to you through Facebook
because it's scale so the highest
conversion selling stuff that I know in
the world is 60 to 80 year olds on
Facebook not conventional wisdom not the
headlines you read but as a practitioner
there's a lot of nuances to figuring out
why it's been working for me number one
a 72 year old on Facebook goes through
their Facebook stream like
this a 17-year old goes through that
same stream like this it's just the
tension arbitrage right so Facebook
cause of its scale
instagrams on its way but Instagram
plays 15 - let's say 4550 on the coasts
it plays 15 to 35 in the middle Facebook
is 25 because it's not winning under the
minute I got on Facebook my daughter got
off fair that's exactly right
it's classic cops-and-robbers right like
you know and and now parents are getting
on Instagram and they're looking
elsewhere and snapchat work cuz it
disappeared we've all been there we've
all locked our room we all wanted a
second phone line we all understand that
dynamic that to me is like secondary
fodder I just want to know where the
attention is Facebook is so ridiculously
underpriced let me explain you will pay
seven dollars to get in front of a
thousand people which thirteen will
actually see it because they'll go
through it but you're gonna pay fifty
eight dollars for that same thing in
four years that's all
I don't know so say if you've ever run a
Google AdWords campaign the word wine
cost me five cents a click one day it
now costs me $14 a click marketplaces
are supply and demand which means
there's vulnerabilities in them
attention spans there's a lot of
conversations around this first of all
it's old talk audacity we love to say
new people are not as good as us because
we're getting older and closer to the
end and it's our defense right we'd love
to talk about the Millennials
entitlement ninety percent of the people
I know that I grew up with in their 40s
we're lazy and entitled to
that's just Americans that are you know
it's funny there's a lot of truth to
that right but that's a hell of a lot
better than Europeans who aren't even in
the game by the way the Chinese are
gonna kill everybody because that's the
way you by the way you know Tracy about
China they run their country the way we
run our businesses our businesses our
capitalistic with dictatorship like it's
really funny to watch it all play out
nonetheless I'm not worried about
attention spans because I like when
things are all equal it's back to metric
neutrality as long as every other person
I'm competing with is dealing with the
same ramifications then I'm cool right
and I think that's the part that's
making it so interesting as the
technology's advance we get put into
more of a playing field that's equal
which takes away a lot of the advantages
we had historically and that's the rub
retail didn't need to go out of business
we just need to do enough more retail on
e-commerce to break their whole model
because it lowered just enough the sales
where the infrastructure costs of real
estate and and all the things in the
real estate environment right fixtures
and people broke the model so you don't
need a lot to stress the system
attention spans are tremendous if you
give people something they want to watch
I see people watching forty seven minute
videos on Facebook and not watching six
second videos the quality of the content
is the differentiator not the length my
passive on you
how are you I'm great
thank you and thank you some of the
things that you said absolutely I open
it like what so for example the concept
there I'm like I'm the memories wouldn't
you the the concept of Facebook
advertising or using Facebook of b2b
it's like right it to me was brand new
I get it I've always thought about it as
you know consumer-facing have you seen
consumer-facing but from a b2b
standpoint there's a little bit
eye-opening from and and and hope and
I've some great I have some great news
it's for you and everybody else in the
environment like most companies
literally think it's better to spend
$47,000 on a print ad in a b2b magazine
that nobody opens then spend 10,000 to
test how Facebook could work for them
utter audacity nothing else so again I
opening for me in in what what I'm also
thank you for inviting us to ask very
basic questions so I actually appreciate
if you could elaborate a little bit more
on example you gave of does your CEO
know your business who are you trying to
reach so we're a food and greeting
company okay and so we have you know
manufacturers of food products for
example we have we're developing some
very special ingredients you know would
probably love to be able to develop some
sort of Intel Inside type concept love
that we're I understand you know we're a
middle market company so our ability to
spend massive dollars to do that as
Intel can is not there yes but the
concept defining strategies that can
help us do that is fascinating and they
didn't have it either right like that
when you have the ingredient that every
consumer facing product is proud to put
on the front of their package they'll do
it for you your problem is you need to
actually build a brand you need to make
that how many people are aware of what
happened with the Dollar Shave Club I
assume a lot of you are right raise your
hands I'm just trying to get context so
Dollar Shave Club made a video that went
viral and sold their company for
million dollars in four years there's
nothing else really there they did it
but by the way so did Nike with just do
it and so did MasterCard for a fifteen
year period with priceless you make a
video that we all get by Wendy's had a
moment in the 80s it was called where's
the beef
right it works the fact that you could
actually make a three-minute 13 seconds
and a daughter and they have a healthier
life because of your product and the
other part of the three-minute video
showed if they had not had your product
they wouldn't and that just strikes a
chord or the buck icebucketchallenge
the fact you can spend a hundred
thousand dollars to make a video and
another fifty thousand two hundred to
spend on ads against the potential demo
to create the ground swelling to then
drive back to give you the leverage with
the consumer packaged goods so that they
come to you to put the greedy inand
instead of you begging whoever asks
gives up the leverage I can't believe we
live in a world where you have a chance
for that two hundred thousand dollars to
have Procter and Gamble and Unilever and
coca-cola actually reach out to you that
is mind-boggling now I'm not here to
sell fairy dust 20 out of 21 of those
efforts could lose but for maybe singles
Dollar Shave Club was a grand slam for
those videos maybe singles 20 maybe
strikeouts and then you just wasted two
million this is practical but the fact
that ten of them can be double singles
triples and as we start getting smarter
about the creative that actually gets
people to watch it's an incredible time
to be in business you know it is
absolutely frightening like the
gentleman said but it's also
unbelievably incredible you just can't
hold on to the romance of the strategies
and leverage that you had or have or
that you overpaid for just recently it
just doesn't work that way that's why
people go to business so what I would do
if you're trying to be Intel Inside you
actually have to win consumer so you
have to make the emotional creative to
get the millennial mom or the fifty year
old male or whoever your target demo is
to actually start demanding or getting
excited about this ingredient that will
make them live
I'm super fascinated by cricket protein
for example right so I think I'm like
bullish on cricket protein right there's
just a lot there it's just a very easy
narrative for me to sell and everything
you just heard I just have to make
people excited about eating crickets but
you know what's more difficult than that
convincing people forty years ago to pay
for water because it was free so that
and while it's four dollars to get in
front of a thousand people and not sixty
three got it that's why I'm excited
that's what this energy is because I'm
so thrilled that 94% of this room is
gonna wake up in six years read an
article how the years of 2013 to 2018
were the best years to build on Facebook
and all these big companies came out of
it and I want them to remember this talk
and be super pissed they didn't listen
to me I mean it historically correct
that's my currency thank you you got it
Yeah right next to you and let right
side what up let's get going over there
somebody's got to step up for that side
hi ken Zuckerberg hey Ken fascinating
discussion thank you are we since this
room has a lot of sort of businesses
that are traditional yes are we at the
end of the day talking about disruption
of distribution in the middleman I mean
that's that's a key message here and I
guess if you could explain when we have
people that are manufacturing product
selling a traditional channel to a
consumer obviously a lot of b2b how do
you help the CEOs and the senior
management's embrace this in a way that
they can then have the action rate at
ninety five percent not four percent or
three percent then with the success and
the creative yeah
you can't which is what's so difficult
right creative is the variable of
success and it's very difficult I've
been spending last seven years and
trying to close the gap the way you can
do it is by driving down the cost of the
creative if you have five hundred
thousand dollars to spend
and you only get one chance to try
you'll lose and so what I've been doing
is building over the last seven years
the ability to give you 11 at-bats for
that price at the same quality of one so
you're thinking is 10 standard
deviations quicker than most of us I
mean it's inspiring it's terrific thank
you when you bring it back to reality
reality yeah think about a chemicals
company yep think about an ingredients
company how do you make that initial how
do you how do you make that initial step
and it's awesome it's very simple it's a
religious step right or a functional
step to your point it's what I've been
fascinated by getting into bigger
business environments coming from
entrepreneurship in Silicon Valley
through radical things like firing the
CEO right or scaring them or inspiring
them like you can't play in the middle
or what really needs to happen which is
changing the way we incentivize them
like I can't blame you I used to be so
mad at these people like you are such
jerks
you just care about the stock price
being good in three years so when you
leave you buy a yacht you piece of crap
right that's what I thought
I still weirdly think that but I'm Way
more empathetic that the structure of
the whole game has put you in that
position
but here's the really important part of
the question I have unbelievable empathy
but what I try to remind people on a
one-to-one who've really gotten to know
me or in this environment is there's
it's going to happen it's happened it's
happening so what I'm so fascinated
about marketing is because I know a lot
of people here if they spend any money
on marketing or putting it directly in
the garbage and so by taking it out of
the garbage and whether it's a hundred
thousand or three million spending that
right starts giving people in here the
confidence of wait a minute why did that
work and then you start building on it
we've gone from places where Ruby
Tuesday's and model easily where it went
from like being 1% of the way they did
things to 40% not because they liked me
or I was charismatic or I'm clever
because of results so you know you try
every different angle I've been in this
b2b environment nine
1% of my clients don't do it the way
that I want them to I'm trying to be
historically correct and more
importantly my entire thesis why I'm
buying I'm building vaynermedia to
become a consumer packaged goods holding
company I want to build the next Procter
& Gamble on the back of building the
next WPP and I went in because I thought
3G was gonna be over compensated and
heralded in the last decade which clear
they had they have but you can only fire
so many people you have to build
top-line revenue and brand and so
nobody's ever built the complement I am
building the complement for every
Carlisle and Bain and Carl Icahn and
Bill Ackman on earth I'm in the process
of it which is why I can see this I'm
being very patient I'm eating my own dog
food that I'm trying to get you to which
is run a marathon not a sprint
because you don't realize the sprint
game is not even gonna be in it's not
gonna be in the Olympics anymore do you
understand that's the problem and so how
do you do it you suffocate them right I
mean it you suffocate the decision maker
you through sheer will
through frightening through inspiring
through data I don't know but you have
the actual conversation
let's get that dude all the way over
there you know we went far right
it's binary right you know like I can
give you a million new heights binary
they either decide to do it or not but
marketing is the most movable thing I'll
repeat it for everybody
yep
yep
my brother I invested I bought marks
parents shares in 2008 on a discount on
a valuation that was 10 billion and I
put every dollar I had in liquid into it
my financial advisor my parents my
contemporaries my mentors they [ __ ] on
me right next it went public all my
friends because I was an early investor
an advocate all my friends that were two
top hundred employees there 90% of them
sold 90% of their holdings between 12
excuse me 19 and $40 a share depending
on their timing six-month you know I I
bought it in 2000 I haven't sold one
share I bought Twitter back to your
question I never fully finished
answering it why not Twitter I bought
Twitter at the same time forty-seven
thousand dollar investment that was
worth sixteen million dollars to me and
I sold 90% of my holding at $44 right
it's 20 now because I just they trade
attention I'm not emotional like the end
like you want to make a lot of money put
all your liquid into Facebook and Amazon
that you can never touch as long as Jeff
Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg are alive and
running it you will win guys
this hasn't started yet that you know
the the shrug is cuz it hasn't started I
love how people think disruption like
everything you see being disrupted right
now tiers tier 3 Auto how does a car
dealership survive in the 40-year macro
when Tesla goes direct to consumer
because the government and the laws are
gonna protect you for how long
it's just naivete and short-term
thinking at scale thinks it's been
eye-opening for me as well you've talked
a lot about day trading attention yes
b2b b2c yes but as a bank where we're
also sort of a middleman to a certain
extent you're in deep [ __ ] too so
apart from hosting you at our conference
and being the keynote speaker what can
we do I think you need to look things in
the eye right you need to actually not
say you can't be in conferences like
this and say here the you know in a more
conservative environment and say over
the next 10 years Amazon or venmo or
blockchain are are disruptive or
potentially disruptive it's really no
different it's gonna be the same answer
for everybody at that scale banks have
to realize what their value prop is and
how quickly it's being commoditized and
it's happening fast right so I think
it's about creating new products and
services I think it's about M&A activity
and grossly overpaying for things that
look like you're overpaying for them I
was on CNN the day after Facebook bought
Instagram they paid a billion dollars
Instagram was 551 days old and Piers
Morgan goes okay Gary Vee what do you
think and I go they stole it I get out
of the studio in Columbus Circle and
10,000 people on Twitter tell me I'm an
idiot because they'd never heard of it
at a billion dollars sure sounds like a
lot of money by the way side note I
favored every one of them and two years
later on a trip to Turks and Caicos I
went back and replied to all of them and
said now what I think the biggest thing
the biggest companies here can do is
grossly overpay for the future but they
have to be right right but that's what
they need to do you need to buy up other
services if you believe what I believe I
could be wrong I've been wrong before
but the core of what a bank does that
its essence is being disrupted very
quickly you do not put blockchain back
in the bag it may not happen bitcoin
could go to zero that's irrelevant you
have an entire generation that
understands the deceleration the
decentralization of us interacting with
each other when you understand that you
are gonna close a house on aetherium
between me and you and we will accept
that it goes into a totally different
place I think people are very naive they
don't understand how religion happened
that's what I think
sir yes yes so I'm gonna almond
processor oh yeah I'm sorry where's this
coming from
right here we're in oh hey sorry okay
um we'll do that we'll do you quickly as
one note I'll get out of here don't run
too late for almond processing company
to export to 70 different countries do
you expect Amazon to accept Bitcoin and
how will that affect a marketplace I
believe crypto currencies were crossed
over the chasm I expect that I expect
China Russia and America to have a whole
lot of say on this issue and I don't
know how the citizens in our world will
react to it so I don't know I'd be I
don't you know why I love what I do up
here I don't guess everything you've
heard so far is fact you just don't see
it that's me guessing my intuition is
Jeff Bezos wants to dominate at such a
scale he has such internal ambition for
legacy that he'll go as hard and as fast
as he can
that disrupting everybody as long as the
government's allow him to but you know
this by playing in 70 kind of European
DNA versus US DNA versus China you got a
you know you're gonna have fragmentation
at scale just like you've seen from
Google and Facebook everybody create
closed Gardens what do you think America
is trying to do right now and you're
gonna see some reactions then so we have
to figure that out
thank you thank you sir you talked about
the importance of brand yes we've seen
you know brands that were icons yes
tarnished yes new brands come out of
nowhere what are the most important
values in a brand you look for RC the
biggest reason big brands get tarnished
aka irrelevant is because they take
money and put it directly in the garbage
right
the reason the biggest brands are losing
right now is because they think running
television ads is worth their 70% of the
allocation of their money the end this
is historical you want to really learn
something if you're a nerd go look what
happened in the late 40s and early 50s
when we transitioned from a primary
radio society to a primary television
society the biggest brands in the world
died right because they went to the club
with the guy that sold him radio
misjudging where people are paying
attention you know this keynote has
content right whether you like this or
not this was content if nobody was in
this hall right now it would have been a
bad use of my time
that's how brands lose and there's
another part they become vulnerable to
the person that's closest to the
consumer in 1982 the biggest
supermarkets and super stores in this
country basically got zero trade dollars
from the biggest brands in the world and
Pillsbury and Kellogg's and everybody
else was able to spend all their money
on marketing as Walmart and Albertsons
and Publix got smarter and started
making people pay for shelf space
support their internal ad networks and
everything else they started taking
money out of the suppliers right and
putting into their own pockets and then
it became a drug because it was great
for short-term sales and then they took
that drug money and started creating
private labels and commoditized the
biggest brands out of the world Wow then
the BRIT biggest brands in the world
still spent money on television because
the biggest media companies in the world
push television down their throat with
[ __ ] metrics from Nielsen's and
others because that's where the margin
is for the biggest holding companies in
the media world leaving brands like
Pillsbury Doughboy and Tony the Tiger
left for dead got it thank you thank you
let's end it with this who are you
sending this Kino to leave a comment in
the section that subscribe
you
[Music]